foreign
ER in Layton what's up Kyler
hey Dr John how's it going good man
what's up
oh I'll just I'll start with my question
and then I'll provide some backstory
after that
um so my wife and I we've been married
for about five months and we're in the
process of
adopting my two-year-old nephew
my question is because why not why not
why why wouldn't we right why wouldn't
we just pile on well just say like so
what somebody says we're hot we're we're
adopting our nephew here's what that
says to me
family is a train wreck
um it's a mess we got picked or we
stepped in and said we're dealing with
this and we now and you put that on top
of we've been married five months this
is incredible go ahead keep going am I
right
uh pretty much I've got one side of the
family that is a little more
dysfunctional than the other but don't
we all don't we all that's right that's
right
um so my question is is how do we set
effective boundaries for not only the
biological parents but also for the rest
of the family
um okay and this all kind of
spearheaded about couple weeks ago we
made the decision that we want to change
this child's name
he's named after my brother
um we feel like that name was kind of
it's mounted in trauma he hasn't had a
great start to his life and
we want to start a new chapter
um
and that that part of that is his name
for us
so
my other brother got involved I have two
older brothers
um the middle one is the biological
father and then my oldest one I sort of
feel like they're ganging up on me and
my wife
um I feel like I'm disrespecting
um the biological father by changing the
name
um and everyone seems to have this
opinion and to be quite Frank Dr John I
don't care for anyone's opinion I'm just
trying to survive yeah so I'm trying to
do the best that I can
let's be a hundred percent candid
ate
that you are disrespecting your older
brother I'm not suggesting he doesn't
deserve that
but looking at him saying I'm taking
your son from you because you can't
handle this child or you're abusing this
child is child's not safe with you so
I'm going to become this child's new dad
and I don't even want him
he's not your name isn't even worthy of
this kid so I'm taking it off
like yeah that's I mean that's a slap in
the face to anybody's kid ABS absolutely
and I'm not saying he doesn't have the
right to be hurt
um or anything like that
um
I just I feel like I've done research
I've talked to people who have been who
have been both adopted and have gone
through the adoption process
um the caseworkers have told me it might
be a good idea to start with
I don't feel like this was just a oh I
hate my brother kind of a thing I love
no no no I don't I don't think I don't
think that at all um here's what I think
uh
I think you haven't fully thought
through
what let me let me say it this way by
adopting this kid
you are opting out of the family as it
normally operates
and I don't think you fully absorb that
yet or metabolize that
your family cannot and will not function
as it once did
and I think what you're doing is noble
and the right thing
just the way family was done before is
over
and your your Middle Brother the brother
the father of this child feels like they
got a loophole which is they're gonna
have access to their kid and still be
the dad they don't have to do any of the
Dead work
and so if you're gonna truly be the the
uh
parent and guardian of this kid there's
gonna have to be some space and distance
between biological dad also knowing that
in our current world there is no way to
have deny access Forever at some point
right that little boy wants to know who
my dad really is and why am I not with
my dad what was so bad about me that dad
left me
right
and so here's what I'm trying to take
take the
romance out of this
this is gonna be hard
right
and everybody's gonna have to act like
an adult I hate that your oldest brother
isn't
um
who didn't step up and offer to take
this kid I'm sad that he thinks he can
armchair quarterback this too
you see what I'm saying
yeah yeah absolutely
I hate that for you so do you all live
together do y'all live by each other
my two brothers they live in Salt Lake
they live right near each other so we're
probably 20 minutes 30 minutes away and
then my wife and I live
um a little further north but okay it
may be considering that Utah's not for
you guys for a while
okay
that's I and I'm thinking through I'm
just all I'm doing I don't have any data
or any sort of research to back this up
I'm just trying to put myself exactly in
your position what I would do
like you're talking about changing his
name that tells me that there are some
deep reasons that we are cutting ties
and so
you can't cut some of the ties and hope
all the time the rest of the ties just
untangle themselves it's not how they
work
what do your parents think about all
this
um my dad
um he is a recovering addict so he's
kind of in and out of jail but
um he's been sober lately and he is I
I'm just gonna stop you right there like
he didn't get a vote and I don't say
that I don't say that mean but
he's sober right now so he used to be
dead for a few months while he's clean
that's just not how that works
he can't toggle in and out you're a guy
that's been on your own for a long time
aren't you
um I've had a great mom she's been a
single mom and she's
she's amazing
but I am kind of a the caretaker of the
family
so you made a bold move and again the
words I'm using can be taken either way
I'm taking this as a good thing you took
a you made a bold and brave move you
can't you can't care for this child I
will foreign
take him away or did he did your brother
surrender him to you
and he eventually
um after a couple of months he was going
to the parenting plan and not kind of
doing what he needed to be doing and he
then signed him over to us okay
but I mean that was with an agreement um
I I didn't take his child
um that was never the intention and we
had many conversations
beforehand like what this would look
like is he an addict
um I think he has a marijuana problem I
don't know if he does anything else my
oldest brother and I grew up with my mom
and then he kind of grew up in many
different households because he was
living with my dad okay
so he had a little bit tough for
upbringing
let me back out of because I'm going on
a rabbit hole here let me back out a
little bit
okay
I would be willing to bet that you and
your wife had your own independent
pictures of what Parenthood was going to
look like
you and your wife also had very clear
pictures of what your first couple years
of marriage was going to be like dude
y'all were going to be doing it all the
time
and wherever wherever it doesn't matter
and y'all are gonna go on vacations and
do cool stuff and pay off your debts
y'all can do all kind of stuff
and now it's gonna look different
already out of the gate and where I see
couples get sideways is they go do a
unified thing together
but the way it was going to look and
feel while they were doing this thing
they miss each other
right and so you and your wife have to
constantly stay connected
this week looks different how do you
want this to look last week looked
different how do you want this one
upcoming one to look you all got to stay
really plugged in together on this
we're really trying we do what you
recommend kind of every Sunday morning
we we sit down we have breakfast we talk
about how the week's going good oh it's
so good dude is that helping
it's helping so much
um we went through a bit of a rough
patch we were pretty stressed
um in the beginning I say in the
beginning we've only been married for
five months so I guess it's the
beginning but dude if you've already
figured it out after five months you win
write that book you'll be you'll be rich
right there
we're trying to we're trying to
um um yeah this little boy's life can
only be as good as you and your wife are
connected
and that's a controversial statement I
don't care
I I agree 100 and and we do I mean my
mom and my wife's mom are very good
about watching him so we can call on
date nights
um once a week we try to do that awesome
we're trying to keep our lives um you
know we're 22 and 24 so we're still
trying to be
young but fun or but parents can I tell
you like of all the things like
everything you're doing is noble and
you're it's gonna be hard and it's going
to be messy and it sounds like you don't
know what's coming but you know
something hard is coming and you're
stepping in that Gap anyway which is
awesome
I can't get my head around changing that
little boy's name tell me about that
[Music]
like here's what it feels like it feels
like an immature attempt to erase
something that you can't erase
that might be true like like I said I'm
22 and I'm I'm not and we haven't done
anything yet and if if people are
speaking into my life that I trust are
saying don't do it then it would be
something we would reconsider but
what it comes down to is this little boy
has been neglected
um he was taken from his home for 32
days
um my brother my brother really let him
down
um and it breaks my heart to to hear
that name
called to my I mean he's my son Dr John
it breaks my heart to see that name or
hear that name associated with a new
with what I consider a new baby he's
he's new and it's not that I want to
erase my brother and it's not that he
won't know at a very very young age that
she was adopted and this was a situation
and your dad loves you and this is who
he is it's not that we want to keep him
from him it's just that I think this
this baby deserves a new beginning
um and this is this is kind of the way I
thought it might be a good idea it
sounds like the babies not the one that
needs the new beginning it sounds like
you do
can you elaborate on that
you're the one that can't stand to hear
that name not him
yeah
yeah that's probably true
um
here's I don't have any skin in that
game
I don't have any skin in that game
um
if the if the
people in your life who have kids who
are speaking into your life the mentors
you have and I would ask non-family
mentors okay
um I don't know what what your faith
background is I don't know what your
cultural background is I don't know any
of those things that would lend itself
to the power and importance of a name so
I don't feel good about speaking into it
other than to say this feels a lot more
about you than it does this kid
and I want you to make sure you never
use your kid
to make you feel better about yourself
or ever do things with this kid so that
you feel better about filling the blank
and if you can learn this lesson at 22
at 23 at 25 you will be so far ahead of
other dads me included
um but this little boy will know this
for his entire life that half of me is
my mom and half of me is my dad
and the demon when dads leave their kids
or dads choose to
uh or unable to I'll say it that way uh
keep their kids
is that kid asks forever
is half of me bad too
is half of me capable of leaving two
and so your love and your connection is
going to be it's gonna be a Lifeline to
this kid
on top of that question underneath that
question to the side of that question
that will haunt him for a lot of his
life
and
I don't know I'll have to think about
that one I've never heard that in my
whole life somebody's saying I'm
adopting somebody in my family and I've
changed the name because
this kid is better than your name
um ask some people in your community in
your in your cultural background in your
faith community the wisdom on that
um just check yourself is this new name
a new start for this baby or is this new
name start for me when it comes to your
wife
um man you are on the path it just
continue to check in
and create a culture that when she says
I need this or I'm scared about this or
I have a gut feeling that so and so is
going to show up and try to take this
kid tonight or so-and-so gets drunk and
I don't want to run my kid that you are
able to go I hear you let's see if we
can make this happen
and and vice versa that y'all are
constantly working through that it's
gonna be a rough go no question it's
gonna be a rough go
sounds like you're the right folks to do
it
being as young as you are and as newly
wed as you are surround yourself with
mature couples who are 10 years 15 years
20 years down the road from you and make
sure you've got people that you trust
that you can ask wise counsel from
thank you so much for being a guy that
steps up in this community my man that's
you're a blessing